the biggest war in Europe since 1945
began Before Dawn
missiles struck across Ukraine the
unthinkable a new reality
[Music]
one of the first targets was this Border
guard post in the north hit by a Russian
drone
foreign foreign
tanks rolled across the border after
weeks spent massing in Russia and
Belarus their goal to seize Ukraine's
capital
outnumbered and outgunned Ukrainian
forces tried to outsmart their enemy
instead
Belarus is literally on the other side
of this bridge on the first day of the
war Ukrainian forces seeing Russian
tanks and artillery heading in their
Direction blew up this key crossing
point they also destroyed a Railway
Bridge about 20 miles in that direction
it's a tactic they've used repeatedly to
frustrate Russia's advance
[Music]
but the invading forces had alternative
routes and not just by land
some of Russia's most elite paratroopers
assaulted an airport Northwest of Kiev
a key Target on the way to the capital
and the theme of an extraordinary fight
this Ukrainian officer described the
first exchange with Russian helicopters
blasted out the sky is
hostable airport is a testament to the
battle for Kiev that raged for weeks and
ended in retreat
the nearby town of butcher among those
most scarred
a mass grave here triggered Global
horror
but the Trail of Terror traces right
back to the border with Belarus straight
through this place
yahidni a small farming Village
Tanya took us to the basement of the
local school where Russian troops
effectively held more than 300 villagers
captive for almost a month including
over 60 children
actually
she stayed in here with her husband and
their two boys
no ventilation barely any food and bombs
dropping outside
um
foreign
but Salvation came too late for as many
as 12 mainly elderly captives who died
down here some of their names scribbled
on the wall
outside we met Alexi and his wife
he lived through World War II but
nothing could prepare him for the
basement
at 86 he emerged from the ordeal as the
oldest person in the village after those
more elderly than him perished
is actual
one of them
is
given us
yes the memory is too painful
things could have been even worse
a 40-mile column of armored vehicles had
been bearing down on Kiev amid warnings
the capital could fall within days
then attacks like this started to happen
Ukrainian drones smashing Russian tanks
the modern day David vs Goliath
this man is known by his team as the
father of the Drone after developing a
model that's now used by Ukrainian
troops
important were the drones in Ukraine
winning the battle for
kievable uh
and they're changing the character of
War
a commander told me how small groups of
Ukrainian Defenders using quad bikes
drones and sniper rifles attacked
unsuspecting enemy vehicles at night
they went after Russia's supply lines
because without access to food Fuel and
ammunition even the mightiest Army will
fail which is exactly what happened and
the capital was saved
[Music]
life even returning to the streets of
Kiev as the focus of the war shifts East
but no one here is complacent
everyone aware Russia's military machine
May yet return and try again
debrahim Sky News Keith
[Music]